if you give two athletes the exact same
training program and they both put in
100
effort their results will not be
identical
this is a simple truth that most people
recognize but it raises some interesting
questions
to what extent is our physical destiny
set is there any point in training for
skills and traits that don't come
naturally
what are the mechanisms of these genetic
limitations and advantages
how do we maximize our genetic gifts and
minimize the impact of our weaknesses
while many things are up for discussion
when it comes to your physical makeup
something that is non-negotiable is an
individual's physical dimensions that is
to say the proportionate length of limbs
overall height and insertions
limb proportion is a subject that has
been gaining more recognition among
coaches
particularly as it pertains to movements
like the squat the simple truth is there
is no one correct way to squat
ankle and hip mobility play a big role
and some of this is genetically
predetermined
for example a lifter with a longer femur
thigh bone versus tibia shin bone
will need to lean forward more into the
squat we can gain more ankle mobility
but we sure can't get longer tibias
short of some painful
years long surgery just to be clear i am
not recommending that surgery
then there's hip socket depth if you
have a shallow hip socket and
thick femoral neck then you will
experience a reduced range of motion
other factors play a role too like the
femoral neck angle
which refers to the way the top of the
thigh bone angles likewise the
comparative length of your arms compared
with your legs is of course going to
impact on the way you deadlift
this is why we shouldn't judge the squat
technique of others without having
trained them directly
nor should we dogmatically force
ourselves to adhere to impossible
standards from coaches
that have never met us in person of
course limb length also impacts on the
distance that a weight needs to be moved
squatting a weight at six foot eight
inches involves moving at a greater
distance than squatting
at four foot eight limb length also
works alongside tendon insertions which
we'll get to in a moment
of course the length of your limb also
limits the amount of muscle you can fit
into a smaller space
likewise the size of your frame will
ultimately limit the amount of muscle
you can pack on
but of course it takes longer for a much
taller person to look dense with muscle
as they require more work to fill that
larger space
the tendon insertion is the point where
the tendon connects the muscle to the
limb
this is a crucial aspect of strength and
performance consider the biceps brachii
this muscle originates at the scapula
that's right this muscle can also act on
the shoulder joint
and then it spans the elbow joint to
insert at the forearm tuberosity
of the radius and fascia
contracting shortening the bicep brachy
has the action of closing the joint
angle of the elbow
essentially this means that the elbow
joint is the axis or the fulcrum
and the forearm is the lever arm
the closer the insertion is to the hand
the resistance the shorter the lever arm
will be
this then means that it will be easier
for you to lift the weight with the same
amount of force coming from the bicep
conversely the distance between the
origin and insertion is going to
directly affect the length of the muscle
belly
which alters the capacity for growth as
well as the appearance of thickness
aesthetic features like the gap between
your pecs or how low down they sit on
your chest are also unfortunately
predetermined therefore
this means you cannot simply copy
someone else's workout and expect to get
the same precise results
keep in mind too that you may have
optimal insertions for one muscle but
not another
this is one reason we find ourselves
gravitating more or less to certain
moves and exercises
if you want to excel in your chosen
sport learning how to play to your own
strengths and compensate for your
weaknesses
is absolutely critical here's something
amazing
there are multiple muscles in the human
body that are only present in a
percentage of the population
incredible right for example the
palmyrus longus is a thin tendon that
attaches to the bottom of the wrist
but is missing in 16 of people there are
many more examples and this just goes to
show the huge amount of variation in the
human race
is metabolism genetic this is a big
subject to delve into but the simple
answer is to an extent
and this is critical let's imagine that
you take two identical athletes in terms
of height and insertions
you give them both the same training
program and they work equally hard at it
with the same dire and rest protocols
do they turn out identical still no why
because they will vary in terms of
plasticity this is one of the most
crucial features
that will determine your success in
training your body is designed to adapt
to its environment
which includes habits and goals but how
rapidly the body changes shape in
response to that stimulus
is what will determine the ultimate
outcome muscles adapt to the environment
through hypertrophy
motor unit recruitment mitochondrial
density and fiber type composition
changes likewise occur in the tendons
fascia and bone surrounding the muscles
given the same amount of training two
muscles may grow at different rates
simply due to variations in specific
hormones and chemicals
these hormones are at least partly
responsible for what we describe as our
metabolism
and that same metabolism is also
responsible for how quickly you lose or
gain
fat the distribution of fat is also
genetically determined
which is why it's almost unanimously
agreed that you can't perform
spot reduction to remove fat from a
certain region
it falls off in a genetically
predetermined order
countless genetic variations will impact
on your metabolism which will directly
impact on your energy levels
your weight loss and even your mood this
is partly what separates the world into
hard gainers and
the lucky ones but keep in mind that the
whole endemorph ectomorph mesomorph
thing
is about as helpful a framework as bmi
which is to say not very
as you've probably grasped at this point
it's a lot more complicated than that
perhaps the most striking example of a
genetic difference affecting metabolism
is the extremely small percentage of the
population born with mutations causing
myostatin deficiencies
myostatin is a protein produced by the
human body that causes the breakdown of
skeletal muscle tissue
variations affecting both copies of the
mstn gene result in some people and
animals becoming myostatin deficient
this is one of the closest things to a
natural superpower and can result in
huge increases in muscle mass
up to a hundred percent increase with no
serious side effects
although this might increase the
likelihood of tendon injuries
this is also why calorie counting won't
work for everyone
not because there is an exception to the
first law of thermodynamics
conservation of energy but rather
because we can't accurately know how
rapidly the body is burning through
those calories
no simple calculation will give you an
accurate resting metabolic rate
as it can't account for those hormonal
differences as i often say
you may not have hyper or hypothyroidism
but you might have a tendency more
towards one than the other
it doesn't pay to think entirely in
binary genetic differences in
testosterone growth hormone thyroid
hormones and even receptors that allow
us to respond to those hormones
will make some people more responsive to
training than others but again the
metabolism itself can be trained and
hacked to an extent
you can keep your metabolism higher by
spiking it more frequently with
intermittent exercise
throughout the day you can even control
your physiology to an extent by changing
your state of mind
different foods varying amounts of sleep
and even the ambient temperature will
likewise impact on your resting
metabolic rate
one of the most hotly debated areas of
functional training in particular
is fiber-type composition as most of you
will know we have three types of muscle
fiber
although the distinction isn't quite as
clear-cut as all that in reality
these are type 1 type 2a and type 2x
type 1 muscle fiber is slow twitch and
is less powerful
but highly endurant type 2a is faster
and stronger but quicker to fatigue
type 2x is faster still but also
comparatively very rare
marathon runners have large amounts of
slow twitch muscle fiber which allows
them to run long distances without
tiring out
high jumpers have lots of faster twitch
muscle fibers which gives them the
explosiveness necessary to leap great
heights
bodybuilders need fast twitch in order
to build bigger muscles as this type of
fiber is larger
some people claim that fiber can't be
changed on the whole however most
research suggests that genetics only
account for around 50
of variability in the makeup of fiber
types on average
so while you might have a bit of a
tendency towards either insurance or
explosive activities
it's also true that you can train to
become better at the other
it has been known for a long time that
it's possible to convert type 2a fibers
into type 2x and vice versa however this
is very difficult and the change usually
occurs in a downward trajectory
meaning muscle gets less explosive
however there's now ample evidence to
suggest that type 1 can be converted
into type 2a
and vice versa as well it's also worth
noting that explosiveness and power are
not just functions of fiber type
we can become more explosive via neural
changes that enhance our rate of force
production
by allowing for greater rapid
recruitment of larger motor units
comprised of fast twitch fiber likewise
you can increase max strength by
building
more muscle thus making those fast
twitch fibers thicker and stronger
the efficiency of movement can also
translate to faster and more explosive
action
so to contend in hysteresis it's also
possible to make slow twitch fiber
behave more like fast twitch
and vice versa so while you might be
slow to respond to training
you should keep at it place a specific
demand on your body long enough
and you will change to some extent
the same is true for cognitive
performance where greater neural
plasticity brain plasticity
will mean your brain changes more
quickly in response to training
thus they will find learning easier both
in the classroom and when learning motor
patterns
a more plastic brain may even see
greater recovery from stroke and other
catastrophic events
but note that more plasticity does not
always mean better
after all if our brain change shape in
response to everything
then it could pick up bad habits as
quickly as good ones this is complex
there are multiple different forms of
brain plasticity that can be measured in
distinct ways
these range from differences in the
number and strength of synapses to
variations in dendritic spine formation
again you could enjoy optimal
performance in some areas while not in
others
the good news is that there are
mitigating factors and methods you can
use to increase your plasticity levels
seeing as this is something that most
people don't train it's easy to get an
advantage here
even if you weren't dealt the best hand
in terms of genetics the best way to
enhance plasticity
keep learning the more you subject
yourself to novel stimuli that requires
adaptation
the more you will produce the chemicals
to support that change
getting more sleep also helps plasticity
as does consuming a healthy diet
consisting of many plasticity supporting
nutrients
the bottom line is this while i'm all
about telling people that they can be
anything they want to be with the right
training
the truth is that some people are just
born for a specific sport
stand next to a professional rower and
you'll likely find that they are very
tall with long limbs
great muscle endurance and great latin
insertions at my stocky five foot eight
inch frame
i'd be unlikely to ever compete with
those guys at that sport with all the
training in the world
but this is a good thing this is an
argument for training cross
cross-modally
as the vast majority of us will never be
world champions in any one event
it makes sense to train ourselves to be
better at multiple things to fully
express our unique potential
these systems all work together and so
we will gain unique and amazing
advantages
by simply taking our strengths and
maxing them out it's also an argument
for adapting training to your own
limitations
and not comparing your results to anyone
else we are so
entirely unique
and don't be disheartened while you
can't grow taller once your growth
plates have closed over
or change your tendon insertions the
real takeaway should just be
how truly plastic the human body is how
adaptable
you have countless mechanisms designed
to help you adapt your environment
and this allows for incredible
individual expression on top of your
unique starting point
the things that people have trained
themselves to be able to do in some
cases are truly
remarkable even your genetics can be
changed thanks to gene transcription
training diet and lifestyle factors
won't change the contents of your
genetic code
but they can change which genes are
active and which are switched off
thereby leading to permanent changes to
your anatomy that can even be passed on
to your children
your fate is still very much undecided
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like and share around
that helps me out immensely as many of
you know i have a new print book
currently available at amazon and
several other retailers for pre-order
that book is functional training and
beyond which is a detailed look at how
functional
training can benefit individuals and
athletes for better real world
performance and health
i'll put a link to that in the
description down below of course you can
also still get my ebook and training
program
super functional training right now that
book is currently on discount whilst
we're all in lockdown
and offers a training program diet plan
and more to help you improve your
physical and mental performance
if you want to see more like this then
hit the subscribe button and
notification bell
to get alerted to future posts i've got
some really exciting stuff on the way so
stay tuned
stay safe and healthy everybody and
thank you so much for your support
bye for now